c'est dans ce hangar désaffecté qu'une
nouvelle usine pourrait voir le jour
dans les prochains mois un site où
seront fabriquées des ampoules nouvelle
génération incassable économes en
énergie le propriétaire du brevet est
une société chinoise qui a décidé de
nous confier l'exclusivité de la
production et de la commercialisation
sur le territoire européen
parce que ils ne sont pas à même de
faire cette opération eux mêmes ils
préfèrent se réserver la production à
leurs marques leurs marchés domestiques
tandis que nous nous allons pouvoir
produire en euros un projet qui pourrait
en appeler d'autres
ces industriels et banquiers venus
spécialement de chine pourrait investir
à brienon sur armançon dans les
prochaines années
centre d'appels entreprises du bâtiment
les projets sont nombreux
maintenant pour moitié ce qui nous
intéresse c'est quand nous installant
sur ce territoire
nous pouvons bénéficier de main d'oeuvre
mais aussi d' avantages fiscaux
c'est aussi une porte d'entrée pour
accéder à l'union européenne et son
marché ici toutes les conditions sont
réunies pour permettre aux entreprises
chinoises de se développer
si les chinois s'intéressent ton à cette
petite ville de l'yonne c'est aussi
grâce à son maire récemment jean claude
carra s'est déplacé jusqu'en chine pour
attirer des investisseurs c'est un pays
qui est en pleine révolution
industrielle qui est qu'il veut s'ouvrir
à la france à l'europe
et je crois qu'il faut savoir travailler
avec eux si les communes ne se développe
pas si les communes ne font pas venir de
nouvelles activités n'ont qu'un choix
c'est de régresser et c'est pas du tout
notre solution en attendant que les
projets se concrétisent en coulisses les
négociations se poursuivent
une nouvelle délégation chinoise est
attendu dans la commune la semaine
prochaine